du hast diesen satz bestimmt schon mal
irgendwo gehört jede zelle in deinem
körper wird alle sieben jahre
ausgetauscht
du bist jetzt aus komplett anderen
atomen als noch vor sieben jahren
aber stimmt das wirklich und wenn ja was
sagt das über dich aus bist du überhaupt
noch du
wie so häufig im leben ist es nicht ganz
so einfach wie der satz vielleicht
vermuten lässt deren unterschiedliche
zellen in deinem körper haben auch
unterschiedliche lebenserwartungen und
erstaunlicherweise liegen viele davon
weit unterhalb von 7 jahren die zellen
in seinem verdauungstrakt zum beispiel
eben nur circa fünf tage nach ihrem
kurzen lebenszyklus sterben sie ab und
werden durch neue zellen ersetzt die
zellen in deiner haut leben schon etwas
länger und werden alle zwei bis vier
wochen erneuert
deswegen hält die sonnenbräune auch nie
allzu lange an wenn man sich nach dem
urlaub wieder viel drin aufhält rote
blutkörperchen überleben mit einem
halben jahr noch etwas länger und die
zellen deiner knochen halten mit circa
zehn jahren im vergleich richtig lange
durch aber es gibt auch zellen in deinem
körper die niemals ersetzt werden und
die du ein ganzes leben lang behältst
zum beispiel an zerebraler cortex im
gehirn sterben diese neuronen ab können
sie vom körper nicht mehr ersetzt werden
so etwas kann dann zu demenz führen auch
werden teile deine augenlinse oder
deiner zähne niemals ersetzt deswegen
stimmt es nicht so ganz dass wir alle
sieben jahre ein komplett neuer mensch
sind teile von uns wechseln jede woche
und andere teile bleiben ein ganzes
leben lang bestehen
aber woher wissen wir so etwas woher
weiß man welche zelle gerade ersetzt
wurde und welche schon seit jahren im
körper arbeitet zellen sehen sich doch
auch unter dem mikroskop zum verwechseln
ähnlich die antwort ist atomare
strahlung durch die vielen atombomben
detonation während des zweiten
weltkriegs und des kalten kriegs steht
die hintergrundstrahlung weltweit
drastisch an
so ein anstieg führt dazu dass in der
atmosphäre mehr stickstoff zum
radioaktiven kohlenstoff isotop c14
zerfällt
dass sie 14 in der luft wird dann zum
beispiel von pflanzen aufgenommen und
landet durch das essen und die luft in
unseren körpern und damit auch in
unseren zellen und da wir wissen wie
verstrahlt unsere erde zu welchem
zeitpunkt in der geschichte war kann man
einen direkten zusammenhang zwischen der
menge des kohlenstoffisotops in der
zelle und dem alter der zelle herstellen
im groben gilt je mehr radioaktives zu
14 in einer zelle vorhanden ist desto
älter ist sie auch stuth eine zelle und
wird mit neuen stoffen wieder aufgebaut
dann befindet sich danach weniger c14
ihr und sie wird schwanger strahlen als
ältere zellen durch diesen cleveren
trick können wissenschaftler
herausfinden welche zellen des körpers
im durchschnitt wie alt werden aber das
wirklich krasse am zellstoffwechsel ist
die schiere anzahl der zellen die
ständig ersetzt werden
allein von deinen roten blutkörperchen
werden jeden tag 200 milliarden
ausgetauscht das bedeutet dass jede
sekunde zwei millionen rote
blutkörperchen in dir sterben und dass
sein körper auch jede sekunde zwei
millionen neue produziert und jetzt
stell dir noch all die anderen fällen in
deinem körper vor die ständig absterben
und neu produziert werden
dein körper ist eine riesige baustelle
diese großen zahlen kommen natürlich
daher dass eine einzelne körperzelle
mikroskopisch klein ist und wir in
unserem körper sehr sehr viele davon
haben wie viel genau kann man nur
schätzen aber eine aktuelle studie
schätzt diese zahl auf 37 2 billionen
zellen in einem durchschnittlichen
menschen
wenn man das kombiniert mit der anzahl
von atomen die eine zelle ausmachen
interessanterweise eine sehr ähnliche
größenordnung circa 100 millionen atome
da kommt man auf grob geschätzt 10 uhr
27 atome die dicht zu dem machen was du
jetzt gerade bist nicht mehr und nicht
weniger
aber es wird noch viel unglaublicher
diese astronomische vielen atome die in
einem riesigen tempo ausgetauscht wie
cycles und erneuert werden lassen uns
eine logische aussage treffen
viele atome die jetzt gerade in deinem
körper sind gehörten einmal albert
einstein oder william shakespeare oder
galileo galilei oder jedem menschen der
jemals auf der erde gelebt hat und nicht
nur eine handvoll davon sondern je nach
schätzung über eine milliarde
durch den schnellen austausch von zellen
und damit atomen in einem geschlossenen
system der erde muss zwangsläufig alles
recycelt werden und atome verbreiten
sich schnell werden sie erst einmal von
hier ausgeschieden vermischen sie sich
in windeseile und verbreiten sich
überall auf der welt
dieser gedanke des recyceln ist
inzwischen auch schon übergesprungen
denn nicht nur atome sind nicht neu
gedanken und ideen sind es auch nicht
viele leute sind der meinung dass jeder
gedanke schon mal gedacht wurde jedes
wort schon mal geschrieben wurde
alles was wir tun ist remixen es neu
anordnen in einen neuen kontext bringen
und nichts anderes mache ich hier denn
der gedanke dass nichts neu ist ist
nicht neu aber zurück zu dir und deinem
körper
denn seitdem du dieses video hier guckst
hat einen körper grob geschätzt über
eine halbe milliarde zellen ausgetauscht
man kann zwar nicht verallgemeinernd
sagen dass der körper alle soundsoviel
jahre komplett ersetzt wird aber bis auf
wenige ausnahmen im körper passiert es
eben schon
und da stellt sich mir die frage bin ich
überhaupt noch ich wenn meine einzelnen
bauteile ersetzt wurden
ich weiß zumindest dass ich nicht
derselbe bin wie vor fünf jahren
ich habe mich verändert ich habe mich
weiterentwickelt ich habe dinge erlebt
wien gereist
ich habe meine meinung und einstellungen
zu vielen sachen geändert und ich sehe
auch noch etwas anders aus als vor fünf
jahren
aber ein neuer mensch sein ist ja eher
etwas das man so sagt also ich meine
natürlich war ich vor fünf jahren auch
ich oder das wirklich beängstigende ist
man kann sich nie sicher sein
nichts spricht dagegen dass das
universum mit all seinen bestandteilen
wie wir es heute kennen erst letzten
donnerstag entstanden ist dass wir uns
an vergangene ereignisse nur erinnern
können weil diese erinnerungen in
unseren gehirnen kreiert wurden und
zufälligerweise alle zusammen passen
nichts spricht dagegen dass fotos und
häuser aus unseren erinnerungen alles
was wir kennen genauso letzten
donnerstag geschaffen wurde nichts
abgesehen von einer astronomisch hohen
wahrscheinlichkeit natürlich aber auf
einer logischen ebene kann man diesen
gedankengang einfach nicht widerlegen es
ist theoretisch möglich
ein anderes gedankenexperiment ist das
schiff des theseus aus der griechischen
antike stellt euch vor eine segel
mannschaft fährt auf ihrem schiff über
die weltmeere
immer wenn eine planke am schiff
kaputtgeht ersetzt die mannschaft sie
durch eine neue
mit der zeit werden immer mehr und mehr
planken er setzt und das schiff besteht
irgendwann nur noch auf den neuen
planken ist dieses schiff jetzt noch das
alte schiff mit dem die mannschaft
losgesegelt ist oder ist es ein neues
und wenn ja an welcher stelle wurde das
alte zum heulen wenn ich nur einen
einzelnen planke austausche sorgt dass
ihr noch nicht dafür dass das ganze
schiff direkt ein anderes wird noch
interessanter wird es wenn man sich
vorstellt dass die mannschaft die alten
planken nicht weggeworfen sondern
gelagert hat und jetzt im hafen daraus
ein neues schiff baut jetzt haben wir
zwei augenscheinlich identische schiffe
aber welches ist nun das originale
schiff des theseus eines der beiden oder
keines oder vielleicht sogar bayerische
für seeschiffe denn die art und weise
wie die bauteile angeordnet sind macht
das schiff zu dem was es ist
ich persönlich tendiere dazu zu sagen
dass keines der schiffe wirklich dem
schiff gleicht das die reise angetreten
ist
aber das muss jeder für sich selber
entscheiden die frage ist nur was sagt
das über uns aus wenn es nur um die
anordnung unserer bauteile geht die
richtige positionierung eines jeden
einzelnen atoms dann würde das bedeuten
dass ein perfekter klon von dir auch du
bist aber das kann er nicht sein denn du
bist du und dein clown hat ja nicht dein
bewusstsein deine wahrnehmung sondern
seine eigene und wenn du der meinung
bist dass ein schiff aus anderen
bausteinen auch ein anderes schiff ist
dann würde das bedeuten dass wir nicht
mehr die sind die wir noch vor ein paar
jahren waren weil wir nicht mehr aus
denselben bauteilen bestehen oder und
wieso darauf hören was ist mit dem ich
schon vor einer woche oder sogar dem ich
vom anfang dieses videos weil ich dort
noch ein anderer mensch als ich es jetzt
bin
was meint ihr was macht das ich aus die
bauteile oder die anordnung der bauteile
oder vielleicht noch was ganz anderes
ich bin sehr gespannt was ihr zu dem
thema zu sagen habt ich finds liga
spannend darüber nachzudenken und ich
bin sehr gespannt was er dazu sagen
werdet wie man ich werde jeden einzelnen
kommentar lesen und wenn ihr fragen habt
gebe ich mir sehr viel höher
alle fragen zu beantworten
übrigens ist das hier schon die sechste
folge meiner kooperation mit dem wdr und
planet schule die hälfte ist hast du
schon vorbei wenn ihr noch mehr
spannende wissens videos finden wollt
dann schaut euch mal auf der website von
planet schule oder like deren facebook
page beide links sind unten in der
beschreibung verlinkt ansonsten
verabschiede mich von euch bis nächste
woche donnerstag wenn das universum
wieder kreiert wird und ein neues doktor
watson wieder rauskommt ich freue mich
drauf